نعم اترك الكاميرا تنقل الصوره الشوارع
هنا مغلق سيارات للشرطه ااا منتشره عندما
داخل هذه الشوارع لمنع الوصول اليها من
خلال حركه السيارات وحدهم المشاه يستطيعون
الوصول الى هنا ولكن فيما عدا هذا القطاع
الذي انا موجود فيه تحديدا شارع في
الدائره العاشره حيث وقع الاعتداء يوم
الجمعه فيما عدا هذا الشارع فان الحركه
تبدو في باريس طبيعيه ولكن طبعا الشوارع
التي ستسلكها التظاهر بعد قليل
ستمنع حركه السير فيها الغضب الكردي لو
سمحت لي مرده الى انه من بين القتل
الثلاثه الجمعه السيده كرديه هي امين كارا
ناشطه على مستوى القياده الكرديه اقليميه
ناشطه مع اكراد العراق واكلات سوريا
واكلات تركيا واكراد ايران وما يثير
التعاطف معها هي انها كانت تقاتل تنظيم
داعش في شرق وشمال سوريا واصيبت خلال
المعارك ضد داعش ونقلت جريحتا الى فرنسا
حيث قضعت للعلاج لفتره وكان الطلبه اللجوء
السياسي في هذا البلد بالاضافه الى مقتل
عازف ومؤلف موسيقي ايضا شاب قتل وهو كان
من بين الضحايا الثلاثه ثالثهم هو رجل مسن
قتل في هذا الشارع الذي استهدف المعتدي
بعد ان توجه الى المركز الثقافي التركي
استهدف ايضا صالون لتصفيف الشعر يديره
الكراء ويستهدف مطعم كرديا هذا الحي
تاريخيا يقطنه الاكراد بكثافه ويديرون فيه
مؤسسات التجاريه في عده زوايا من هذه
المنطقه الواقعه في الدائره العاشره هذه
المحال التجاريه التي تشاهدونها من بينها
عدد كبير منها يديره اكراد المنطقه يتواجد
همم الاكراد منذ وقتا طويل وهم ما زالوا
يتذكرون الاعتداء الذي استهدفهم في التاسع
من يناير من العام 2013 ولم يبقى مرتكبوه
عقابهم هذا احد اسباب الغضب الكردي الذي
ترجم يوم السبت الماضي مواجهه كبيره